los conservadores saben que va a ser muy
difícil sostener la legitimidad del
gobierno sin irse a elecciones generales
en un tiempo relativamente corto y si
ese es el caso muchos conservadores
piensan que su mejor carta sería Boris
Johnson quien siguen siendo una político
carismático y muy popular entre los
miembros del partido
pero no dice esto a la vez que el
partido a su vez está muy debilitado
para que tenga que volver a recurrir a
Johnson
de eso no cabe duda el partido
conservador en las encuestas más
recientes aparece si no en el tercer
lugar hasta en el cuarto lugar por
debajo no solamente del laborismo que
está muy por delante de los
conservadores en este momento sino
también de los liberales demócratas y
hasta los nacionalistas escoceses ello
ha encendido las alarmas en el partido
conservador en verdad es difícil ver
cómo pueda mantenerse el partido en el
gobierno por supuesto
oficialmente no tiene que irse a
elecciones generales o no tendría que
hacerlo sino hasta enero del 2025 sin
embargo va a ser difícil que pueda
sostenerse la crisis social la política
y económica está golpeando con mucha
fuerza a los ciudadanos Y estos están
expresando su disgusto con un partido
que lleva más de 12 años en el poder se
habla de John
que puede cada uno de ellos aportar al
partido conservador en estos momentos de
crisis
crisis una que aparece como una
conservador más moderado una alguien que
tiene
más
estabilidad y experiencia en el manejo
de las finanzas y le daría al partido
conservador y en particular a los
mercados
alguna sensación de estabilidad
mientras que Johnson por supuesto sería
una buena carta electoral
es menos conocida es más poco probable
que ella pueda hacer la candidata de los
conservadores pero ya vemos aquí una
intento de recambio genera